construct a circle circumscribing the
triangle so that would be a circle that
touches the vertices the three vertices
of this triangle so we can construct it
using a compass and a straight edge
which is or a virtual compass and a
virtual straightedge so what we want to
do is Center the circle at the
perpendicular bisectors of the sides or
sometimes that's called the circumcenter
of this triangle so let's do that
and so let's think about let's try to
construct where the perpendicular
bisectors of the sides are so let me
make us let me put a circle right over
here whose radius is longer than this
side right over here now let me get one
that has the same size so let me make it
the same size as the one I just did and
let me put it right over here and then
this allows us to construct a
perpendicular bisector if I go through
that point and this point right over
here this bisects
that's bisects this bisects this side
over here and it's at a right angle so
now let's do that for the other sides so
if I move this over here and I really
just have to do it for one of the other
sides because the intersection of two
two lines is going to give me a point so
I can do it for this side right over
here let me scroll down so you can see a
little bit clearer so let me add another
straightedge right over here so I'm
going to go through that point and I'm
going to go through this point so that's
the perpendicular bisector of that's the
perpendicular bisector of this side
right over here and I could do the third
side and it would intersect it should
intersect at that point I'm not ultra
ultra precise but I'm close enough and
now I just have to Center one of these
circles let me move one of these away so
let me just get rid of this one and I
just have to move this Center this
circle to the circumcenter and adjust
its radius so that it gets pretty close
to touching the three sides the three
vertices of this triangle it doesn't
have to be perfect I think this exercise
has some margin for error but they
really want you to they really want to
see that you've made it
at drawing the perpendicular bisectors
of the sides to find the circumcenter
and then you put a circle right over
there